North Korea fired two more missiles
overnight casting new doubt on president
Trump's push to denuclearize the Korean
Peninsula this is its second missile
launch in less than a week CBS News has
learned the US has little or no warning
when North Korea fires short-range
missiles ramie innocencio is in beijing
monitoring developments
ramie what else do we know good morning
a US official also tells CBS News that
those missiles earlier today look very
similar to the ones that North Korea
fired just six days ago on Thursday
those short-range ballistic missiles
those are nuclear capable they're fast
they're also very tough missile defense
systems to follow and to destroy now as
to the ones that were launched earlier
today those were launched from North
Korea's East Coast and they flew about
150 miles before falling into the ocean
next month
u.s. and South Korea are planning joint
military drills the North sees those as
a precursor to an invasion and these
missiles could be sabre-rattling to try
to get those stops also today's launches
are now the second since President
Donald Trump in Kim jong-un nets on the
Demilitarized Zone on June 30th that
meeting though had no major
breakthroughs except for some nice
television optics there and further
increasing tensions South Korea said a
new submarine that the north unveiled
last week can carry 3-3 ballistic
missiles and they will be deployed soon
now North Korea has promised that it
would not conduct nuclear tests or
long-range nuclear ange missile tests
but these short-range tests are a clear
provocation also looking ahead Secretary
of State Pompeo says that there are no
dates for any new talks planned
looking ahead Anthony Ramey Inocencio in
Beijing thanks